we talk about Joe Rogan Bill Maher Tulsi
gabbard is Democrats Elon Musk these
Democrats who have come over and and
sided more with the conservatives
recently
it goes way further than that Tim
Robbins one of the biggest lib actors in
one of the biggest lib Industries
obviously in Hollywood he just came out
and he admitted to Russell Brand that
the covid lockdowns
changed his mind
we went into lockdown with healthy
people with children and that didn't
seem to be wise to me so
um I'm not a scientist I'm not a doctor
I don't know the intricacies of of uh
data on this all I can respond to is as
some someone that has is concerned about
what the result of those
doctrines that policy had on us as human
beings and it's not good we turned into
um tribal
angry vengeful people
and I I don't think that's something
that is sustainable for the Earth that
we
start demonizing people that don't agree
with our
particular Health policies and turn them
into monsters
look I'm not a scientist look I don't I
didn't I didn't know but
this wasn't good
that is the opinion
of a lot of liberals
who initially bought into all the covet
hysteria and Dr fauci and lockdown and
six feet apart and wear the hanky on
your face and Trust the signs they
started out seriously believe me some of
us didn't start out believing that okay
some of us I don't want to name any
names here okay I don't want to toot my
own horn some of us understood what
kovid was from the very beginning
some of us when they tried to lock us
down and actually forced us to lock down
in California some of us were back in
the office within 36 hours because some
of us called up Jeremy boring and said
Jeremy I'm not doing this this is all
ridiculous I'm showing up to work
tomorrow and he said okay I understood
I'm already at the office
okay so I'm not saying who would have
done such a thing it was me it was me so
some of us knew it and I'm sure many of
you knew that from the beginning as well
but there were a lot of liberals who
very earnestly believed
the science and the lab coats and the
masks and the fauci
and then realized wait a second
are we the Baddies
they had that reaction wait or
the thing that we all clamored for we
huh maybe those crazy right-wing
fanatical Republican extremists Maybe
maybe they were onto something
covid-19 is being called
the great reset
not just by tinfoil hat people but by
very very powerful Elites
Klaus Schwab the head of the world
economic forum
his various Associates
Yuval Harari one of the philosophers
behind the great reset the world
economic Forum Bill Gates
world leaders you you see this with King
Charles of England you see this with
lots of other political leaders you're
saying covid-19 is the opportunity to
reset our economy and our food
production and our political order and
our technology and our and what is the
great reset always amount to
it amounts to eat the bugs live in the
pods give up your rights own nothing and
be happy
surveillance everywhere
no political sovereignty
it's a it's a reset of our very Humanity
that's what they want it to be
and that's insane and terrible and we
should fight a tooth and nail
but covid-19 provides another
opportunity for another great reset
covid-19 provides an opportunity to
reset political alliances I don't think
that I am being overly optimistic here
or hyperbolic there are lots of people
who got very red pilled during covid
during the lockdowns
a lot of people who trusted the entire
liberal establishment for their whole
freaking Lives who said wait they lied
to me about this they lied to me in such
an egregious way what else have they
been lying about
and this is the moment for republicans
and conservatives and just normal people
to capitalize on that and say yeah come
on in come on in Tim Robbins the water
is warm
this is this is not just your 1980s
battle
between the left and the right and the
Democrats and the Republicans
politics means applying Eternal
principles to changing circumstances and
that means that political alliances will
change over time and one of the problems
with the squishes where they really air
and I think they air earnestly and
unwittingly and sincerely but they find
a lot of comfort in play acting the
political battles of the 1980s they use
all the language of the 1960s through
the 1980s the period that they consider
to be the Halcyon Days of the
conservative movement the days of
William F Buckley Jr and Ronald Reagan
and so they'll use these terms they'll
say we've got to fight the collectivists
we need free markets for the smallest
minority of all the individual and he
has all these cute lines that they heard
in reruns from Milton Friedman and Bill
Buckley and all the rest of them
and they pretend that they're still
fighting Soviet communism as an
international conspiracy the
conspiracies have changed the Soviet
Union doesn't exist anymore the threats
are different okay so I'm not saying
that we need to Chuck out all the things
we learned during that movement but we
have to have the guts and the the
political Vision to fight the battles
that are actually happening right now in
one of those battles the probably the
biggest battle
is not between left and right and
Republican and Democrat and all the rest
of it
it's between the secular globalists
and the traditional
nationalists
the conservatives the people who like
their communities
that Donald Trump pointed this out
he said the Battle of our age is between
globalism and nationalism
and by globalism we're not talking about
the Catholic Empire of the Middle Ages
we're talking about
in the world economic Forum in the U.N
peddling abortion and contraception and
weird bugs and mass migration and
destroying our economies and all the all
the terrible stuff that you have seen
that the libs have used covid-19 to
promote
that's what it's about and so this is
our opportunity are we going to welcome
in the Tim Robbins are we going to win
them over or not are we going to keep
play acting the battles from the 1980s
people are moving over to our side the
rest of the show continues now you don't
want to miss it if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us
[Music]
[Music]